[Music]
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what who walk
through it
hello and happy tuesday this week is a
big one for marvel fans moon night is
ending tomorrow head on back here for
our very first nerd alert live where we
dive deep into all the things from that
and of course may 5th doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
well blows the multiverse wide open now
i had a chance to pre-screen the first
20 minutes of it and i have a lot to say
but you know i can really only share as
much as disney will let me so
let's get into it i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you can't control everything strange all
right so the film hits the ground
running and introduces some characters
we've been waiting a long time to meet
specifically america chavez let me tell
you her first scene is not only
heartbreaking but it's also a sort of
like
peter parker dr strange relationship
vibe
i'm sorry to bother you sir please we
saved half the universe together i think
we're beyond you calling me sir okay
stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it sochi
gomez brings america to life as a
character who's simultaneously charming
kind of goofy and yet totally confident
with the ability to bust down doors to
multiple realities now
very excited to see how her relationship
with the good doctor
doctors
evolved
i had a chance to chat with her over the
weekend and ask her how it feels to be
representing the lgbtq plus community in
the mcu
[Music]
i mean i think it's really important for
you know especially that certain group
of people to feel represented since i
don't think they're um represented
enough you know and i'm just so proud to
be um
the one that plays america and i'm just
so happy that the mcu has chose to put
america in the uh in doctor strange the
multiverse madness and she's such an
important character it's
it's great it's unfortunate that having
a queer superhero means that marvel fans
in multiple middle east states will not
get to see the movie but props to disney
for standing their ground and not
removing the 12-second scene where the
character reportedly references her two
models talking with the pa news agency's
star benedict cumberbatch has said quote
it's difficult not to become emotional
about it to be honest but it is i'm
afraid unexpected disappointment adding
the ban is quote truly out of step with
everything that we've experienced as a
species let alone where we're at
globally as a culture
[Music]
things just got out of hand
and speaking of the doctor himself i
only got to see a hint of this but
benedict will take on not one not two
and maybe not even just three iterations
of the character three are confirmed but
you know marvel wouldn't be surprised if
there were a few more strangest floating
around this film as i mentioned we get
answers about one multiversal strange
defender strange right off the hop which
feels fresh considering we usually wait
a little bit for a reveal like this you
could use an avenger
there are other avengers i'll get you
back on the lunchbox
what do you know about the multiverse
now if you feel like you need a
storyline refresher before entering the
multiverse of madness marvel has
confirmed that watching these four films
and series will bring you up to speed dr
strange
one division what if specifically season
one episode four what if doctor strange
lost his heart and not his hands
and of course spider-man
[Music]
sam has become known for this
terrorizing cinema experience
he's creating as much tension as
possible for the audience just ready for
them to have that jump scare moment
and lastly if you're on the fence about
elizabeth olsen's recent comments about
the film having jump scares you
shouldn't be having seen what i've seen
sam raimi has risen to the occasion
diving head first into the mind-bending
and frightening side of the multiverse
with benedict confirming that the
director's ready to bring the scares to
the mcu
trademark visual styles of bringing uh
jump scares or shot kara and the kind of
horror genre that he defined at a
certain era into
the
comic book superhero genre which he also
redefined 20 years ago but it was
fascinating listening to him talk about
how tech and the ability to communicate
instantly means that decisions can be
made on the spot and they really had to
we were working in conjunction with
three other films or three other
entities in this continuing story uh
this this serial of all serials that is
the mcu so there was a lot of things
that had to change and juggle and remain
uncertain or informed sometimes until we
were committing them to tape on the days
yeah you see the more i listen to that
the more excited i am to see the rest of
this film the professor x mordo captain
carter and monica rambo all shown in
various trailers plus a cameo that is
allegedly fantastic there's a lot we
think we've already seen but you know dr
strange still has got to have a few
surprises up his sleeve what other
special appearances do you think they're
keeping under wraps how are you feeling
going into multiverse of madness week
have you deleted twitter yet to keep you
know
leaks and spoilers away or are you
unable to open reddit fast enough drop
your thoughts in the comments below so
we can chat about it and i'll see you
tomorrow for our live moon night finale
panel
[Music]
[Music]
you